trailer commentaries this week
it's miss marvel but all we're talking
about this week is next week's honest
trailer for gray man
oh wait uh whoops uh raymond love that
great man man we've been complaining a
lot about grandma before we started
filming but let's travel back in time uh
happier times i think when we're all
watching miss marvel um
a lovely series that uh well i liked
everything except for the marvel parts
of it but we'll get into that we're
gonna watch the we're gonna watch the
honest trailer stop and start as we go
along uh we will do some deleted scenes
of which i hope we have a few because i
know we cut some some jokes from this
one and um
uh what else do we do here we do q a so
keep your uh keep your questions coming
in the chat and we might answer them um
yeah i don't want to say that uh i
phoned this one in but
it's comic con week folks um i've got
about 18 other videos uh on my plate so
uh uh lon danielle thank you for for
picking up that slack and uh miss marvel
can i even remember what happened um i
remember a very charming story about a
a muslim girl from jersey and her
community and um going to pakistan that
was fun and her family and her friends
and then all the all the were there any
like super heroic parts of this because
i kind of i can't afford that there's
really three stories there's there's
kamala and her her coming of age and her
parents and her her personal life and
how she sort of sorts out who she wants
to be and this identity crisis she's
having and then there's uh
clandestines which are these interests
bad guys who are trying to get back to
their homeworld and to do so they're
going to destroy our world and then
there's also this department of damage
control
very bad at their jobs an agency that's
apparently designed to like limit the
amount of damage superheroes are doing
but that cause way more damage in trying
to stop those superheroes and they are
also confronting kamala and her friend
right so these three story like
individually i think all three of these
stories work pretty well and i enjoyed
them they just don't they don't
mesh well don't think that they
uh had enough episodes i think that this
would not that i was left like i need
more miss marvel but i just don't think
the stories that they were trying to
tell had enough chance to breathe like
she was she was done with her high
school problems after one episode which
we noted in the trailer yeah like i wish
that they had uh you know let's say 12
so she can have four episodes about her
in jersey four episodes of her in
pakistan and then four episodes of
everything coming together at the end
what do you think overall yeah usually
i'm very much um in the camp of because
you know back when we were still doing
the netflix stuff you would have
something where it would be 15 episodes
it's like you could have done this in 11
or 12. and i agree with you like i think
this is one where i would have liked to
have seen four more episodes and that's
like
a compliment because it's just that i
want to like get deeper into the world
and like
see more of these characters and these
interactions that i really enjoyed um
because if i didn't like it i'd be like
you could have stopped at one um but
yeah so i i do i i would have liked to
have seen more of that and i'm sure
because i i it was so it's so incredibly
charming um
that i and i know that we're gonna get
more of that character but i do you know
i am always a big fan of if you have the
time to take the space to to to do more
of the high schooly stuff like that kind
of that kind of thing um i i do i want
more of that i want more of that i loved
loved all the moments that we got with
her parents um who yes they're strict
they're also the cutest people on the
entire planet um i'm sorry if you didn't
if something didn't happen to you when
her dad comes out in that hulk costume
and she's like you are the lamest person
i've ever seen and i would like oh god
oh i like it oh i hurt um
so yeah like and and and that's another
thing where we get like these great
really human moments where it doesn't
have to be like you know i'm a person
because i saved the cat or whatever it's
just like oh hey like here's like a real
like moment between this family i think
these were creators and the directors
they got to uh to execute these episodes
where that really cared about the
characters in the world that they were
building
but
in terms of um
kamala's life and her family and uh
jersey jersey city but i don't think
they
i don't know i feel like they kind of
yada yada yada the like all the mystical
stuff
it doesn't it's not just that there's
not enough of it i do i agree with both
of you that that's a problem and then it
probably should have been eight or ten
episodes to tell this story that they're
telling more fully it's it's connective
tissue that we're missing it's like it's
like how does kamala's journey of
identity and and you know she's having
these feelings of i live in a fantasy
world and i need to come back to reality
or i need to learn more respect for my
elders and my parents and my community
and become more part of the community
all of these things that she's learning
about herself all these things she's
learning about her family from the
clandestines and from for from her
grandmother all these like like they
need to come together in some way that's
thematically like here's what this show
is about and here's what story we're
really telling about common and it never
quite gets there it always feels like
we're telling a bunch of different
stories that are sort of somewhat
thematically aligned yeah yeah and i
know that we'll get there like obviously
she's going to be back in you know the
the marvel's movie um probably going to
do like a sequel after that or something
like that so we know that we are going
to get there and this is just the first
season those are just like a couple of
beats that i think it would have been
nice to spend some more time and really
hang on yeah for sure i mean like i
totally agree i would have loved more
time with with all of all of these
different stories because i think that
that
a little bit more a little bit more time
to sort of
get us into that world would have helped
in every single one of them like the
department of damage control there is
there's this sort of internal
thank you ryan nicely done oh we lost uh
we lost a monitor oh there's this sort
of internal conflict that is so like
thinly sketched it barely registers it
it's like oh brian on camera oh
we're ryan siding and it's like well why
even bother to do that if you're not
gonna service that story in some way
yeah yeah and also and this is uh true
of really most marvel properties um but
as a as an action franchise i found miss
marvel lacking i don't think i'm not
upset that oh they didn't do the
stretching powers uh exactly like the
comic book cause that would look dumb
she says the word in biggins i got mine
that's all i care i got it i got my
amazing captain she said the word but i
did i did i don't think that there there
were no standout set pieces uh uh from
an action filmmaking standpoint to me i
liked the one where the people like
disintegrated or whatever that scene was
great
but they turned into cartoon skeletons
yeah okay that's okay i get out of here
and the stuff that i mostly liked was
like the you know the the
the and you're right because as far as
the action goes it wasn't like you know
oh my favorite of the action scenes but
i liked like the cutesy directing i
loved the directing in the first episode
yes and the way that all of the all of
that stuff was done like a lot of that
but the quirkiness when it comes to the
action i do like we complain a lot about
this and it's definitely guilty of like
instead of coming up with with what the
powers would be or how they interact
they they they usually complain that
it's goo
and this time they go more for like
glass like char
yeah it's just like char glassy shardy
looking things and it's just like it
doesn't look it doesn't look distinctive
enough to be cool and to really register
all right uh let's watch the honest
trailer for miss marvel but i like the i
agree that i like the the
cartoon elements and adding like the
mitchells versus the machines elements
it's more of the like her powers effects
that i have the issue yeah roll it
like i said don't do ms marvel reverse
psychology on us
a hero can come from anywhere
manhattan
brooklyn even other parts of new york
city where you from
greece but now
the mcu asks you to imagine the
impossible
could anything good come from jersey
yeah buddy time to gt triple l your gym
lay my life on the line for you bunnies
let me slam a hoagie and take a shidoobi
first though yeah so pause this any
excuse to get the situation
the jersey shore cast and i say that
meaning the situation ronnie
uh snooki
paulie d
vinnie
almost there oh you're ronnie and ronnie
and what's her name ronnie you know
there's jenny sammy
and then you're missing one more well
jenny was or that one was on for like
one episode well no angelina is still on
there right and then there and then
there's the champion
thank you well no one you also missed
the other meatball where's my dina love
oh
my point is just to say uh jersey strong
and jersey solidarity with the cast of
jersey shore who put out an open letter
saying that the they have no
uh confidence in the mtv jersey shore
reboot when you say you're sure you mean
they'll you mean them they are the shore
and any attempts oh they're trying to
bring in a new
generation
yeah well like because the original
jersey shortcast is like 40 now like but
and they're still doing the show
snooki's got like three children to race
uh you would be surprised they're still
doing the show where they get together
for like little vacations yeah right
well they do that they do the jersey
shore like family reunions yeah whatever
right so just uh just want a side note
jersey street i had no idea because
paramount plus now has a show called
all-star shore that is it's like the
challenge you remember the challenge
real world rules so this is a challenge
show but all for people who've been on
the various shore shows
so i didn't even realize there were that
many shore shows
you could do a shore verse there's a
there's a there's a there's a short
cinematic universe
that's that's the best news i've heard
all day
all right let's keep playing
marvel
iman villani stars as kamala khan the
first pakistani american in the mcu to
not play an indian guy
when a magic bracelet unlocks her inner
mario maker
she'll join the mcu's next wave of cool
female heroes who have to carry the
heavy burden of standing for captain
marvel i know some of you think well she
abandoned the people of earth but like
look it's it's not true can a woman just
live oh so that's where her stretching
powers went carol dammers went away
she'd punch a hole in space and time and
she'd help them now yeah and then she'd
blow up your brother's wedding in a red
sox jersey
this really uh carol danvers being from
boston really sent me yeah he got down
to home really
a whole thing about carol danvers coming
from because i really think that um
there's a lot of uh criticism levied at
carol danvers character
from uh from me from yeah from she's
getting it from all sides she's getting
it from the alt-right chuds she's
getting it from the film bro from the
you know cinephiles because
for whatever reason i think
where i'm right
well the reason i don't like captain
marvel is that she's not boston enough
carol danvers from boston we have so
many new york superheroes and we have
somebody who grew up in night late 80s
boston given yeah
oh yeah 90s late 80s early 90s boston
she needs uh she needs bruins jerseys on
over that suit she needs to be talking
about the pats and the socks just and
she needs to just dunk in
a dunking
hanging out with all those boston comics
like janine garofalo yes yeah janine
garofalo we can have uh bill burr be the
narrator or something like that for next
movie i want that scene where she's
regaining her memories and uh or or not
regaining remembers just like being
filled in on what was happening while
she was gone and she finds out that tom
brady like just won four super bowls and
she just blasts a hole in a mountain
just like yes
she needs to make captain marvel captain
marvel yeah that's the campaign
right now make her make uh make captain
marvel boston again i would like to say
for the record because now i'm sure
we're getting a lot of emails and
comments like i'm i'm not anti carol
danvers like her personality or i like
brie larson just fine i just it feels
weird to me that that kids would be like
captain marvel's my favorite avenger
just because she spends so little time
on her the other avengers are like
personalities in the media they're
they're broadway musicals broadway
musicals they have ben and jerry's
flavors they're making podcasts they're
on tv they're writing books they're
fixtures in your life captain marvel was
like here for 10 minutes like sure
ant-man's talking about her on a podcast
maybe but you wouldn't i don't feel like
you'd feel that personal connection if
she's often i don't think she's been on
earth since
no she said that's end game since and
that was she flew in and then flew out
she's been like 20 minutes on earth
since the 90s like it just feels like
how would a person really connect with
her
yeah i think they need it they need that
because she's going to take on you know
she would love kingo
she would not love kingdom no she would
be i'm kidding she would love one of the
other avengers who's around more yeah
black widow yes your black widow is a
great choice yeah there's no but that's
the thing is there are so many
great female heroes going forward but
generation one it's like black widow
you're really really into the wasp the
wasps
yeah pepper potts as rescue was there
for us oh
yeah yeah yeah no and even learn about
shari and nakia now
wakanda's opened itself to the rest of
the world oh shuri would probably be a
big one because the young girls would be
in to be like oh yeah i'm going to go
into stem sure i'm sure a lot of uh like
emo goth young women feel a little
betrayed by wanda's sudden turns right
yeah that's a lot of people hiding their
wanda tattoos
oh sorry i didn't i named my baby one
like your kids
a lot a lot of times oops a lot of baby
maximoffs out there
just going by max now
amazing uh all right let's keep playing
captain marvel thank you captain marvel
to come out of her shell at school and
learn to be proud of who she is which
he'll accomplish after one episode
then spend the rest of the time running
from damage control the department
disney activates when shuri posts an
anti-vaxx video
i mean the group responsible for
controlling all the damage that they
themselves create they already blew my
apartment
they're all locked into battle against
the clandestines exiles who want to
return to their world even though it's
made of glass shards it turns you into a
spooky skeleton
and gives your only son a cosmic tummy
ache
yeah
i love that disney cartoon where they
all dance together right you want to add
more spooky skeletons to the mcu yes i
want more spooky skeletons in the mcu
yeah that's sam raimi's next entry is
just gonna be all spooky skeletons
isn't that spooky that we all have a
spooky skeleton inside of us i know
right now and just waiting to come out
yeah we're just like three skeletons
talking to each other
flapping yeah
do you ever think about that gross this
is why we shouldn't all do edibles right
before the show oh yes that's why yeah
someone spiked magicians that wasn't she
fueled now it makes sense
yeah daniel dustin dustin daniel yes
yeah
destin daniel cripp he's going to be
directing avengers king dynasty
oh
directing avengers king dynasty moving
up look at that well that's that's cool
he also did short term 12 which is
phenomenal folks if you haven't seen it
all right really great
does that mean he's doing both because
aren't they like being filmed
back-to-back
i don't think they've confirmed that
they're being released they're being
released very close together so they're
being made simultaneously but i don't
know if they're being made like peter
jackson's house together chongchi
director doing the doing the avengers
films
it's great it's one of those movies that
everybody in it went on to be famous
like the keith stanfield is also in it
and i'm blanking out there's like five
people in it went on to become famous a
really great movie i will uh definitely
check that out um it was the one that
was like it was like the brie larson
cross yeah i think that he certainly
that was one of the more um
what's above competent but below amazing
one of the more really good marvel
directing efforts workmen like but
better than working i would say better
on a marvel scale better than effective
i would say a very effective and he's
yeah
the characters of shanxi and his
aquafina themed friend uh were a little
little thin i didn't really care about
them as people well he can direct an
action sequence it just felt like those
were equipment shoes were right
action stuff the the like sort of wusha
martial arts inspired crotching tiger
stuff and all the stuff that's in tallow
that like fantasy realm that they go to
i thought oh that was really awesome so
excited to see him get to dig into more
of the cosmic fantasy stuff because
that's what he really nailed with the
other one all right well you heard it
here first we broke news um look at that
let's watch on his trailer hopefully ben
kingsley comes back
not a great plan
but kamal won't face another poorly
developed marvel villain alone she's got
three helpers spread evenly across the
kind geek to questionable bad boy
spectrum bruno a swagless peter parker
can't really train today
oh we don't hook up with brood no no no
no the hunky movie geek comrade do you
like watch bollywood movies obviously
and the other hunky movie geek kareem
come with me if you want to live what
i've always wanted to say that two hunky
movie geeks in one show
sure
and of course back at home you'd think
they were doing honest trailer
commentaries who starts out not trusting
her at all no i don't trust you but
after her daughter keeps disappearing in
foreign countries for hours at a time
totally learns her lesson and we trust
her right oh that makes sense
uh so when julian i know that you know
she had an arc as she should but i do
feel like they're hamstringing
future uh uh things with this character
feature shows where like you need that
dynamic of the mom is like no no no no
no and she's like i gotta i gotta save
the world mom don't you get it and she's
like no you don't you could stay right
here you could have done this arc and
had them come to some kind of
understanding without it being so much
of a you could be a superhero go for it
in like two episodes it just it does not
i love the actress playing the mom whose
name i don't know she's wonderful she's
very funny yeah like she really sells a
lot of the jokes but i just i felt bad
for her because i feel like they they
don't do a great job actually not enough
scripting her journey to get her
believably to a place where she would
start to trust come on no but bon jovi
you understand she's down just like
which is i mean all that stuff that's
right that accuracy is selling it like i
buy the character i buy her love for bon
jovi i think she's really she's hitting
the jokes really well i just wish they
gave her more of like i would have liked
the show that's just about her and
kamala and their journey together and
you don't need the clandestines it just
feels underdeveloped yeah i wouldn't
mind that it just it feels
underdeveloped because they're rushing
to get in so much other stuff yep all
right maybe she should be like more
street level like you don't need the i
guess you can allude to the cosmic
background but maybe she's trying to
stop
a more neighborhood style crime like i
feel like they were setting her up in
the same manner as like a spider-man or
like yeah including like like we're the
neighborhood we got your back miss
marvel it could have even just been you
don't have them and it's just the
department of damage control and like
they've found a new superhero and
they're trying to track her and she's
trying to avoid them and like as her
powers keep she keeps getting more
powerful you know harder to cover up and
like you could have made that work i i
just feel like they're trying to tackle
so much and it ends up being a little
underdeveloped all right
keep going
the show disney clearly didn't believe
in or they wouldn't have buried the
first three episodes under obi-wan which
is a shame because the directors made it
look cool it's an american show that's
not full of evil muslims for a change
and oh by the way it officially brings
mutants into the mcu there's something
different
in your genes like a mutation
come for the origins of x-men stay for
the origins of pakistan we must go back
to a pivotal moment in the indian
struggle for independence uh pods
total odyssey time
did you learn about the partition of
india from from this tv show no but
no
we're we're uh you know i i was i i
don't
know
there's nothing i knew it happened
like i learned a lot of the detail and
nuance that i did not have before oh
yeah that the yeah that's right
i learned more about that before for
sure but i yeah like i actually felt
like i learned i got something out of
watching this like historically um this
is uh definitely watchmen i had knew
nothing about the tulsa massacre until
richmond so uh you know on a long enough
timeline these are these superhero
problems
something about something please teach
the children
because the schools aren't doing it
children are a future
watch the emcee yeah between triple r
and this show like we're giving a crash
course in indian history to americans
are going to have a brand new
appreciation for this whole indian
pakistan yeah and and british
colonialism well we'll get to that part
here let's keep playing
the fantastic noir
marty mcshy
don't tell mom the super power spread
yeah i've got a girlfriend she's another
dimension though you wouldn't know her
kareem abdul dagar
another mcu nakia how we run out of
character names already
mad about yusuf
diver and cleary damage control oh i get
it the bad guys are dc
quentin tarantino somebody stole my
shoes that joke yeah i really thought
that kind of boss
was gonna yeah and ideas more episodes
you thought they were gonna bring that
back i really think they've they kept
talking about how somebody's stealing
unless that's a thing that i just
learned about like it might be a thing
but like right like that's the thing
that is like recognizable for for the
mosque-goers watching if you're a moscow
or tell us to people steal your people
often steal your shoes but no i thought
she was going to bust the the [ __ ] yeah
in the last episode right yeah oh well
yeah um all right season two yeah we're
leaving there for season keep playing
that's where we find out who hired the
gray man oh no it is
we are trying to drop the name
nightlight that's a bad name it just
sounds like it's for five-year-olds red
daggers
what are you gonna have pakistani boy
band and when you know you're really in
trouble
you're not going anywhere i know this is
the worst possible time to ask but
kamala khan
yeah because he's like related to
yeah you know after watching this in rr
last month i think we can all agree on
one thing
nobody on earth likes the british
did you see there's a there's a guy
today who wrote an editorial like a
british guy who's like it's this rrr
goes too far
mean does brits are like no if you tell
us you hate it it makes us like it more
like
you're totally streisand affecting
yourself also yeah nothing in that
movie's really heightened for uh
ray stevenson's uh
evil evil british uh guy very realistic
performance oh man uh thank you all for
watching this uh we got more uh stick
around because we have more uh and also
other videos like all of our san diego
comic con coverage is coming out uh we
had some fun here with me ed and carolyn
at this desk over the weekend reacting
to all the things uh that was fun and
more coming out this week because we
were interviewing
you know people you've heard about ryan
who who do we interview uh
[Applause]
hollywood celebrities that's enough
names they get it people like that they
didn't didn't bailey also speak with
kesha she spoke with kesha i i had heard
that bailey and kesha spoke about ghosts
i did not wake up in the morning feeling
like p diddy just to find out there's no
footage
uh we also have a twitch channel now
that's up and running uh phantom uh
twitch.tv backslash fandom uh and we
keep threatening to actually watch
movies on there but yeah we've been a
little busy with comic-con we're going
we're gonna do it man
no i'm never watching the great many
great man
not doing it would that be a good one
because you could literally watch
anything else at the same time and not
like not miss a thing it's a it's
actually the perfect one to do
um so on to your questions um
uh evan jay oh and outtakes
first yeah
maybe stick around i don't know
apparently the food here on earth is
great you ready for the best meal of
your life there's just something about
their syntheticness
i just can't resist yummy yummy
chocolate chip cookies the secret
ingredient is nutmeg
no i don't trust you yeah mom why don't
you trust me i'm just joining secret
societies in karachi with knife-wielding
older boys i hate my life
starring
buzz light girl
lieutenant bengal
the wrath of khan
camshaft it's flubber in time
and what our vice president says to
herself before an interview voila please
don't be weird
marvel's jersey girl
the big bengal theory
the marvelous miss marvel great effects
is always hopey yeah is it venture con
an official stark event or did some
third party license the rights to the
avengers and their likenesses cause i
mean who do you even pay for the rights
to groot birch
yeah thank you for your sacrifice tony
and that vision go [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i yourself it was five years before so i
guess people have had time to get over
the loss of vision and he's technically
not human yeah but it does feel me like
he was all deserved by thanos yeah he
should be on your mural yeah some kind
of silhouette at least yeah come on um
all right so uh evan j pretzel says uh
hello evan aside from the sopranos is
this the other good thing to come from
stinking too sits that's what i call
jersey wow
wow
coming
uh
oh well now i need to come up with
another good thing for him
[Music]
listen you count uh caramel corn caramel
corn uh the very first time i had i
believe it was the very first time you
ate
from the boardwalk in new jersey that is
where
and also the saltwater taffy comes from
the basement
that's both delicious
and you know every man i've ever dated
loves bruce springsteen
new jersey they have terrific pizza in
jersey kevin smith is from new jersey
from red bank sure all right there you
go that's that's a list that's all right
let's find the gardens this is the
garden state right yeah it doesn't like
a garden uh arthur mingo asked will they
start on time yeah we did sucka
um sometimes yeah close with the delay
yeah okay
um
uh yamir hades asks uh what phase are we
in our phase is even a thing anymore
we're in i know this phase we're in for
it ends with wakanda forever and then
the next one starts and that's phase
five and that's going to go through the
fantastic four movie
no phase five
phase six starts with fantastic no
that's what i'm saying phase five ends
and then we get the phase six starts
with the fantasy four movie and we don't
know what movies are in phase six except
it ends with kang dynasty yeah the two
and then the whatever the the secret
wars so
all the movies that got announced at
comic-con or all the the stuff that was
bieber that's phase five but i still
don't think we have the
any clear contours of
uh what phase four is
heading up to because we've already
split open the multiverse like seventeen
times
yeah but like i mean overarching
plot-wise like what are we doing here
we're it's what are we moving aftermath
of
the like the of the the snap and then
it's the tears in the multiverse because
this is a transitional this whole saga
like what's ending with secret words is
the multiverse saga yes so it opens with
all these tares and incursions and
problems with the multiverse and then
it's gonna come in five is gonna be
where it culminates in and we have to
face off against kang and whoever the
bad guy is fantastic for is probably
doom i'm guessing and phase six is going
to be the x-men and fantastic four
presumably i mean we're certainly
working i feel like we're already
starting we're gonna start layering in
mutants right like ms marvel's the first
mutant we're gonna start finding out
building up a nice fond of mutants right
yeah
by phase six that mutant roux we're
ready to pour in with the rest of our
vegetables we got a mutant stew
uh pedro vega says this is dead ass
everything i wanted from spider-man
homecoming and didn't get yeah i agree
the first three episodes and i i liked
the paxton stuff too on its own on its
own merits but yeah i really love having
street level neighborhood heroes i think
that's uh this and hawkeye i think are
are great uh places for marvel for
disney plus to live uh gonna get that
daredevil we're gonna get daredevil
we're gonna get like 80 episodes
yeah it's 18 i think 18. yeah let it
breathe
like six blocks squared yeah
a lot of hallways one neighborhood a lot
of hallways outside of manhattan uh so
arthur bingo has a question for question
time what's the best mcu outro credits i
think the first doctor strange is pretty
good
i'm trying to think of what the number
they're all just like
i think i think for me it's gotta be
black panther and it's just because all
the stars
that's it that's that k dots is the song
it's literally just all the stars that's
it yeah there you go it's not the outro
credits but the guardian's two credits
when they're all dancing around and
stuff like that oh that's fun yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was fun
jay pretzel again if we make mcu
characters more in sync to their comic
counterparts do you want to see ben
grimm explicitly jewish in the in the
fantastic four he's got yeah two feet on
oh sinking chairs yeah uh
he's always telling you he can get
products for cheaper yeah
spamalina asks this show could have been
so much better if it wasn't written for
tweens i mean you have a tween protag
not tween she's teen uh protagonist so i
don't know how you avoid that yeah this
is kind of i mean that that is what
this character has always been for the
children yeah like that is what this is
for this this character is for like i
mean it's for everyone obviously every
everything should be accessible to
everyone but this is very specifically
something that is like obviously
uh
teen girls and young young teen nerds
are going to identify with this
character so i think that it only makes
sense to
really push into the teeniness of this
and that's always been how comic books
are too there are comic books that are
for younger readers that are getting
them into this world and then there are
grim dark bloody comic books for you
know the older readers who want to see
violence and you know more adult themes
i think we're all evaluating it in terms
of its appeal as a
teen a younger person show this
obviously isn't aimed at us and yet we
are able to use the powers of uh empathy
or some sympathy or some type of
projection into somebody else's shoes to
say oh this works as that type of uh
as that type of project um
whereas something like the gray man is
clearly targeted at dads and
is a
goddamn the grandma
is it i don't know who it's target my
pops is gonna love it
and that's not i love my i love my pops
but he is going to love the gray man i
wonder if he's already seen it i'm going
to see what he thinks
uh digital firefighters
let's see so um
levetto asks uh who do you think is more
likely to be an honest trailers fan iman
valani or kamala khan and i'll add um
kamran and uh kareem from uh from the
show who who in the mcu is most likely
to kareem hate us yeah who who in the
mcu is most likely to be an honest
trailers fan is i'll open up that
question
ned i'm gonna say yeah
like who's who's the most indoor kid in
all of the mc it's like thor's roommate
todd was that his name
yeah yeah yeah i feel like that's what
we're talking about
uh let's see uh uh lucas has asked w is
asking us a question that relies on us
to pull something from history that's
lesser known boy not gonna happen
what little-known historical event
should tv force us to learn next wow
yeah i got nothing for you please the
defenestration of prague
[Laughter]
that's a when you get thrown out of a
win yeah that's right um
and then a great question from dylan
lambros uh after the hulk first thor on
his trailer will there be any more made
for tv 70s
it wasn't a cold check the night stalker
or salem's lot cole check the night
stalker's amazing and it would be really
fun to do an honest trailer for but
nobody would
click on that um i think
maybe i mean i i want to just try
re-cutting venom as if it is a
made-for-tv uh legal proce journalist
procedural so maybe we'll try that i
think i want to do um i want to do trial
of the incredible hulk oh yeah that
would be really good the one with the
daredevil yeah but uh dylan let us know
uh i i i'll have to look into cold check
let's put it that way i'm not familiar
with it oh it's it was it's like a it's
like a 70s sort of take on like an
x-files like he's a paranormal
investigator like a colombo meets
x-files we are definitely doing a manual
goes to space though oh yeah yeah of
course
um
all right let's move on to your clue for
next week
it's the gray man folks uh wow what what
can we say about the gray man that we
can we can tease you with right now i
mean um
we're debating just scrolling through
tick tock first yeah
i feel like the the gray man trailer
should occasionally cut away to what
tick-tock uh we've been distracted by
while we were supposed to well here's
the thing it's not too late well then
just kind of too late so i don't feel
like working that hard but we but people
are uh going crazy that we mentioned our
are in the trailer so
should we just do our
instead
should we add our r to the
schedule
just give me give me the day to re-watch
rr but yes yeah uh nate turtle saying
better call saul on his trailer when
well when uh ryan gets me season six
cause i'm not paying for that [ __ ]
okay okay great
i need to catch up on scenes you guys
don't pay for amc plus it's terrific
yeah okay dark winds you could be
watching dark winds i could be watching
dark winds right now which is why we're
going to say goodbye
thank you so much for watching
commentaries uh we'll be back next week
for the gray man see you then bye-bye
[Music]
you